two wildfires broke out this week
outside flagstaff arizona forcing the
evacuation of nearly 2 500 homes the
twin spring blazes illustrate the
increasing threat from fires in the west
ahead of the peak summer season with
nearly 41 million acres burned in the
past five years alone new thinking is
emerging on how we combat wildfires
along with growing concerns for the men
and women who put their lives on the
line fighting them here's brooke silva
braga from the wildfire epicenter in
california
in july 2018 a patch of dry summer brush
ignited in shasta county california it
seems like that's the story that gets
played over and over recently
burning areas haven't burned in a long
time
and now people live there
few people were better prepared for what
became known as the carr fire than aaron
humphrey so i
was born in the fire basically into the
philosophers my dad worked on the laguna
hotshots down on the cleveland national
forest
aaron also became a hot shot the
dangerous job of working on a wildfire's
edge and scraping the ground bear to
starve the fire of fuel 20 years in he'd
become the leader a superintendent but
still wasn't ready for what the carr
fire became devouring 500 000 california
acres and taking eight lives the fire
environment created its own weather all
night got about 100 foot wall flame
coming down
i honestly didn't know what to do
and i didn't want to be there
so
it was hard
each of the last two years have had a
fire twice as big as the car
super fires are fueled by dry conditions
that's thanks to a changing climate
they're also harder to battle because
more homes near wildlands mean far more
places to protect but ironically the
chief of the forest service randy moore
says much of the trouble was created
nearly a century ago
by the forest service itself back in
1935 chief still cox implemented this 10
a.m policy every fire will be put out by
10 a.m the next morning what we didn't
realize at the time was the ecological
value of fire now we have an over dense
forest because we are putting all the
fires out
what you have is a greater opportunity
for catastrophic wildfires so moore a
forest service lifer who was long based
in the west has plans to thin 50 million
acres over the next 10 years cutting and
selling what they can but relying
largely on what's known as prescribed
fires down low down low california's
state firefighters are burning too i
want the message to be that not all fire
is bad cal fire's gus boston told us it
gives him a better chance of stopping a
future blaze like the one that destroyed
nearby paradise and when this burn is
successful what will this look like
return it back to where the the brush
isn't so dense but the american west is
so big and so dry burning brush is far
from a silver bullet in fact the forest
service paused their burns this spring
after one in new mexico grew wildly out
of control we have to learn to live with
fire
in fact we are living with fire we're
just not living with it very well
chris scow retired as a forest service
deputy director for fire and says the
ultimate solution will be nothing short
of rebuilding the west we need to have
highways water delivery systems
electrical distribution that can
live with fire being on the landscape if
that sounds expensive it would be so for
now a more brutal solution is being
employed sending men and women into
impossibly massive fires
and hoping they come out okay
often they do not
i don't know how to put this in the
right words but i just felt angry all
the time
i felt anxious and i felt angry in 2019
after his 25th season aaron humphrey
left the forest service citing the toll
deadly fires and severe crew injuries
had taken on his mental health for guys
who do this a long time how common are
mental health challenges
um it's more common than i think anyone
can ever say
humphrey wrote down what he was feeling
just know i'm putting it all out there
so maybe it helps someone and emailed it
to colleagues as a goodbye one to the
forest service i needed real help and
not just talking to friends and drinking
professional help
other letters followed to whom it made
concern i'm resigning after 17 years
with the forest service mike west
detailed his trouble getting treatment
for ptsd the toll on home life and the
pay which even after president biden
intervened last year what i still think
is not enough starts at just 15 an hour
that's far below what local agencies
like cal fire pay if you're putting an
incredible strain on your family and
risking your life you deserve to be able
to support your family without relying
on insane amounts of overtime
west became a teacher humphrey took an
easier higher paying fire job with the
utility company many others left too and
yet the forest service repeatedly told
congress this spring they were on track
to be fully staffed we have brought on
about 90 of that already and we'll get
there 100 percent uh shortly what are
you seeing on the ground that sounded
impossible to scott burkhart a
california hotshot boss who lost 40
percent of his crew this year i respect
their decisions i respect
them going to make more money but it's
hard
the replacements attracted to adventure
and beauty can't always afford housing
you have guys living in their vehicle
affirmative yes
in frustration burkhardt took one of the
resignation letters he had received and
forwarded it to the forest service
leadership along with his own grim
message watching the mass exodus of our
operational knowledge is one of the
saddest evolutions i have witnessed his
resignation embodies every deficiency
that will contribute to the biblical
destruction ahead of us
when we met chief moore early this month
he conceded they had not hired all 11
300 firefighters they were hoping for
currently we're just under 9 000
employees which pushes about 80 percent
moore said his april testimony that
they'd already brought on 90 percent of
their goal
assumed everyone would accept their
offer an assumption that speaks to a
disconnect between the home office in dc
and the firefighters in the forest we
spoke to one person out in california
who said they see this testimony that
says basically everything's okay and
he's saying wait a minute i lost eight
of the 20 guys on my hot shot we went to
a job fair where we're offering 15
and the fast food restaurants are
offering 18. there isn't a sense of
urgency around how dire it is and i know
that that's all true uh you know you can
go to a fast food restaurant and make
more
than what our lower graded employees
were making but that makes your job hard
of course it does it makes it more
complicated okay here we go part of the
solution was promised in last year's
infrastructure bill which included
raises for wildland firefighters if
agriculture secretary tom vilsack and
office of personnel management director
kiran ahuja determined raises were
needed to help with hiring but seven
months later no raises have been given
in a joint statement the agencies told
us we expect to have updates related to
the pay increases out to our workforce
very soon
but that will be too late for the spring
hiring season the forest service told us
this week nationally they are now 90
percent staffed but across california
oregon and washington state
more than a thousand vacancies remain do
you think you'll stay
yeah
i'll be here until i retire
and that that's
why i'm talking to you because i want
this to succeed i want this to keep
going i want to see folks get the
respect that i think they deserve
for cbs saturday morning brooke silva
bragging butte county california
and they deserve a lot of respect that
is tough work you look emotional they
deserve respect and money and more money
i mean paying 15 to someone putting
their life on the line on a daily basis
trying to save other people we talk
about this with service professions with
police with fire obviously in this case
these these wildfires are something that
can affect so many we need to treat it
the same way we talk about it with
teachers oh yeah the people that we
trust the most that's the basic
infrastructure of our kind we have to
find a way those two cabinet level
members and president biden hopefully
will be talking about this and are
watching the show to see it